[Music]
what's up burger world Alva kai-lan for
the burger show we're live at complex
con some of the most creative geniuses
all get together and show off all of
their creativity I am blessed to have
bars and garu right next door and if you
don't know what that is that is the
burger joint by Takashi Murakami one of
the most iconic Japanese artists in our
day and there's so much murmuring about
he has a burger with all this stuff on a
truffle his bun is stamped with the
flour I want to show him what my burgers
about I want him to show me what his
burger is about and maybe our girls who
collide let's see what the [ __ ] happens
[Music]
so Takashi the longer hair at complex
con yeah right this year it's the year
of the burgers yes I hear you have one
of the most phenomenal pieces of art
that we get to eat in the form of a
burger and I have my hometown classic
from East LA I have Wagyu beef guacamole
and I have jalapenos in a Hawaiian sweet
roll this is like from Southern
California yeah I made it for you with
love and I can't wait to try your burger
yeah can we exchange yes please please
thank you thank you
Kashi yep tell me what's in this burger
okay so very bottom Iza exactly lettuce
and a tempura stuff the base double pin
tempura okay I see the key that is you
know Paul got things and then this is
exactly what you think okay and truffle
from from the French bus from France yes
well if you don't mind can't wait to try
this yeah okay enjoy all right
[Music]
what do you think I end up this is
amazing
Oh job Oh spicy very crunchy so much
flavor with the truffle you can tell us
some good topples guys unreal so
obviously you designed everything you
know my friend of the French chef he you
know he'll pull up everything the recipe
or something
Wow just I'm making for a design team
you design yeah yeah
do you love burgers that's my heart I
see you're wearing a bib is the next
move custom bibs oh yeah you want to
work together on a custom bib oh yeah
yeah we're gonna make a custom bit it's
a costume yes I'm gonna ask you a
question that everyone needs to know in
and out or Shake Shack what do you like
better
oh baby because you know I don't know
now as I was yeah sorry yeah you know by
default baby
Takashi thank you so much for your
burger thank you for enjoying my brother
yes very much I did most of all thank
you for being an inspiration for all of
your creativity and your beautiful
artwork thank you so much thank you
appreciate it yeah I would have is that
you yes Tom thanks Kahn burgers above
all Takashi
Alvin it's gay baby
you
you